what's up everybody welcome back to kind
of funny I'm game spots co-op stage at
e3 2017 how are you audience I like to
hear
you were loud enough that the one guy
playing Tekken was like what and turned
around but now he's right back to Tekken
7 asking this question I'm one of your
host Greg Miller alongside the pier 110
Gettys lets him host and from easy
allies Brandon Jones love and respect
thanks for happening did you mic on
talked into it well now if you don't
talk well yeah I think so there we go
few nights get some Randy Jones love I
like it I like are you plugged in Oh
excellent how having a great time as
ephraim you've been treating the allies
really good yeah yeah no no big
complaints so far I think we're really
digging everything that we're seeing so
alright awesome awesome
now Tim yes what you wanted to bring to
this segment was arguments yes I want
controversy all of you it you want to
argue about who had the best conference
the best press conference of III 2017
now real quick who had the best
conference this year that's not even a
question
get hyped everybody miss Takeo is back
they brought Mario they brought Metroid
Prime they announced the new Pokemon yes
thank you
where's Nintendo there's Nintendo
they're behind us you probably can't see
that sections over we're done which we
won our jackets yeah Brandon do you
agree that Nintendo ran away I mean I
saw you to see Ubisoft in its entirety
and I thought that was the that's what I
hear is the front-runner why do we say
that really sure she thinks that they're
the winner for sure mr. Teague's paid
off hahahaha I said it so it also
challenged one debate see what did you
like out of Pokemon from the Nintendo
like what just the fact that we know
that it's coming I understand that
sounds and we're getting a net for
console Pokemon game made by Game Freak
rice is it poke at Turner it this isn't
some you know Pikachu and Magikarp
friends or whatever the hell this is a
core Pokemon game on a console a just a
come on its although its ways away it
wasn't happening like did you were you
concerned that like oh they're finally
done with that Pokemon process I don't
think it was the concern that it wasn't
happening
it was the police because they lied
oh nothing like that would happen it is
well I'll tell you about a lie this is
something as me off and I see in press
conferences sure I hate the like oh I
just happen to be at my desk thanks for
coming by like let me tell you that like
I did the staging of yeah I was just
drawing Pikachu here now presentation is
very very important but let me take you
back Brandon the reason I'm excited
about this the reason it's important for
them to announce because you say Oh
obviously they're doing this right
do you remember the WiiU not many people
do I tell ya I remember when it first
came it was like you know what this
launch doesn't seem good
next e3 we're gonna get our Metroid
games are gonna announce the Pokemon
console game we're gonna get the next
Mario like the next big thing no we did
never happened we didn't get that so now
that the switch has come out we've
gotten great launch games launch game on
you know this couple other things
happening we know we're getting the next
big Mario and it's awesome yeah we now
know that the pokemons coming right it's
like all their major franchises are
coming soon or than later yeah which is
awesome I'm gonna hit you on a
technicality though yeah because the
Metroid return of Samus was technically
not in the Nintendo spotlight which I'm
okay with stage I'm totally I'll try to
just sneak that in there and I'm not
buying it no I don't never know that
you're trying I'm trying for what yeah
yeah no the return of Samus that's
awesome I want to say I think was the
more exciting announcement not that like
that games gonna be better than prime
but like we saw it they played like a
lot of dog names on TS instead to me I
don't even I'm here yeah I mean I'm will
be playing it but I am excited for
Metroid fans now here's the thing taking
my fanboy isn't back a bit I understood
yeah a fanboy of Nintendo I understand
that a lot of the announcements made of
the Nintendo thing that I'm really
excited about are things that are years
away and are just they're just kind of
empty right it's logos or literally just
a guy trying Pikachu I get that but on
top of that we get Mario we get fireman
warriors coming up we get all this stuff
and I feel like they did a really good
job of kind of letting us know what the
rest of the year looks like and giving
us a glimpse into the future and I think
that was a really important question
that I had as a man that they answered
yeah now get it off a Nintendo for a
second I feel like a lot of the other
conferences I don't think there was a
bad conference this year I think they
were all at least good sure EA was a
little frustrating and Bethesda was
super short yeah but EAS was just so
traditional
in terms of like hey we're ei and here
are all the games you know about and
will promise you sorrows will promise
you Star Wars
here's way too much Star Wars yeah oh
yeah trailers great here's 30 minutes
we'll see my pleasure my too much Star
Wars I need to see 30 minutes 30 minutes
of battlefront 2 was a bit much of the
car but it was one of the only like
honestly live we have no control over
how this is gonna play out demos that we
saw in any of those and that's for
example why you shouldn't do that in a
press conference you don't like that
excitement that bomb like I think I
legitimately JIT emit Li got 34 kills
live and that's that's officer I am own
that match that was not rehearse but to
me that is a post conference if you want
to see this here sure I keep saying the
press conferences are kind of like when
you watch a movie and see all the
trailers before it you don't have a
choice of what trailers are put in front
of you but that enforces you to watch
all of them and be exposed to things
that you might not have ever clicked on
or seen before but with the press
conference I feel like they're coming
down they're going to announce names
announce games announce games when they
focus for way too long on one you're
alienating so many people and I feel
like EA still doesn't quite get that
when they come out because I understand
then that it needs to be there and that
NBA LIVE needs to be there and all and
FIFA obviously but why does that take up
45 minutes
sure could take up 10 what what's the
impact it's it really hard for me to
gauge is that like I know FIFA has a
huge audience I know they're really
excited about getting updates but are
they really tuning in to this conference
like are they really like the audience
is now the time to really focus on them
let's try to juggle that pre-show post
show how do you do it because it's Sony
did the same thing Nintendo did which is
just like you have this conference where
all eyes are on you but then Sony use
their pre-show to announce you know I
released a show everybody's golf show
all these different things that people
wanted you and now supermassive games
one other three or whatever and then
Nintendo at the end is putting the
return of Samus there it's like I'm
taking all these announcements that you
would traditionally see as just a sizzle
reel I think you would have had more
eyes on it you know shoo shoo a [ __ ] it
was on the show early and he was talking
about the fact of like if you didn't
watch our pre-show it is up on YouTube
we announced a bunch of games yeah it's
like wow that's maybe the problem in
terms of marketing that information like
this Gabi way to deliver that in a fast
here we go I I disagree because I feel
like especially with the Nintendo thing
I think
putting it after the conference gave
Nintendo another spike of news stories
and it was another moment of light but
wait there's more
yeah but they I think they left that
message not get out the right way right
we it was people tweeting about it of
like hey I work for Nintendo you need to
see this it seemed it seemed to be a
last minute sound the Klaxons
everybody get over here and look at it
right in the same way that then EA had
it miss balanced I think of having that
giant pink piece of Star Wars there but
I think would have been better served up
awesome [ __ ] trailer for battlefront
then hey everybody we're signing off but
if you want to watch 30 minutes of
battlefront stay right here yeah and I'd
be like oh yeah right and I think even
Nintendo's things should have ended then
like hey Mario is great everything's
thank thank you all we're gonna get a
million ounce five new games in this
post show actually house to stay tuned
yeah first playstation even use I'm a
pretty big PlayStation fan and I totally
missed the messaging that they were
going to now stuff during the free show
like what audience are you serving do
you think that is directly combating
like Joker's like us to do our own
pre-show Sony's like no we're gonna you
can talk about what we're gonna do but
we're actually going to do stuff so
you're gonna watch us and yes no I think
it's the ever changing landscape that is
video games where it's like we people
are learning the power PlayStation knows
the power now with PSX
of activating your fan base and they
will come and they will support you and
does it out how do you do that at e3 I
think next year they're going to have a
hey there's the press conference but in
the parking lot there isn't open to the
public thing where we will announce
stuff and you can wash along live with
us because they need to manage this
we're now we have 15,000 fans here who
are treating it like a pax or like a PSX
you can double down on that use that a
really interesting way and I think it's
interesting to see people struggle with
that what do you think about like you
know comparing something you know like
how Numa being like oh I have the master
sword in my hand how did that happen you
know versus like Ubisoft like Miyamoto
running on stage with the cannons and
like that it's that like that was I
think I think I liked about Ubisoft is
it had Hart character you know had
passion like it would that work just
like a couple of like legitimate
emotional highlights like it just kind
of felt a gap and I really felt it the
whole way fight my thing is I feel like
presentation for a press conference is
one of the pillars one of the most
important things obviously the game
isn't important to you Tim is that
something you focus on absolutely I
I think I love it I think when it comes
down to it that the on Bethesda
conference did such a good job of
getting in and out and making things fun
and to just segue to things and we might
have known everything from it but it was
presented in a way that I feel respected
our time and there wasn't stupid
gimmicky stuff and like the Bethesda
land stuff was the glue that hold it all
together whereas I feel like Nintendo
directs they still kind of have those
awkward moments they don't know what we
love about Nintendo now if you like this
Reggie coming out being like would
unlock and like those everything's
falling down around him in this weird
computerized world and he's got a switch
it's like alright your Nintendo still
yeah I have a feel very interesting him
being like here's when the splatoon
tournaments gonna happen it's like maybe
not in your own yeah when he finds what
why doesn't that double back I would
think - hey that's part of a treehouse
announcement we're gonna really talk
about what that is or a pre-show thing
of like a sizzle reel telling you over
and over and over again I'm like this is
this tournament this yeah yeah I don't
know I feel like in terms of content
Nintendo's the clear winner I think in
terms of presentation they're not I
think that it's a toss-up between
Bethesda and Sony
I thought Sony really stepped up their
game this year in terms of making it
entertaining to watch and yeah they
lacked a lot of the gut punches that
we're used to the last couple years for
them responding mean Shadow of the
Colossus remake like that was a genuine
surprise for me where I would have never
thought that was going to happen that
was awesome that was that I was talking
to so many about it today Ryan if like
oh man you didn't like the PlayStation
Frasca oppressing I was like I know
something I'd like it it's just after
Grand Slam after Grand Slam after grand
slam to hit a home run you're like
alright dad good job hitting one you
know like a lights like yeah it was a it
was a solid conference I liked all those
game and Ashley being here Dow and
seeing those guys and like being able to
look at them and like see behind closed
doors it's like these games are gonna be
amazed in terms of conferences like
personally it's the library I'm most
excited about it's the one that where
the majority of games spoke to me but I
can't you know when I'm watching the
Nintendo one be taking back my neck well
when they surprised us when it was that
first game that was 2018 they're like
whoa you said you weren't gonna do that
and then like Nana here it goes yeah
that was awesome that was a cool moment
what was your read on Microsoft uh I
thought it was fine I think we were
talking about flow like I think they
actually do a good job of I love
the theater I love the shrine when Sony
had it there because it really gets a
sense like we're at the opera video game
but it does get a little you know
relentless and kind of tiring when it's
just like another trailer another
trailer another trailer and I do love
that because it gets right to the point
but like I know some people that hated
the Bethesda land you know motif but I
liked it because it does kind of guide
things you know there is like you can
see the transition moving from one thing
to another and I think just
presentation-wise Xbox does a good job
of that like now we're up in the corner
over there and now we're over here and
now we're gonna bring player you know
unknown over on this side yeah so I
thought it just had a nice flow that way
and I thought I thought they did a great
job of having quantity of games like
there was like when they came out
they're like we're gonna have 42 yeah
like oh yeah man like this is this
getting real they mean business with
this I feel like they did a pretty good
job of getting out of the ex
conversation pretty quickly where it's
like here's what it is you have to wanna
do you don't let's get to the games
who's gonna buy an xbox one X well this
is awesome
one two three four no one no one let me
try again slap don't raise your hand
don't do this rug thing who's gonna buy
an xbox one X golf lap boy what do you
think about saying 42 games ahead of
time though cuz like that is one thing
that irks me a little bit is like the
cockiness like that's why I didn't like
Battlefront because they're like we got
the campaign now it's like well you
should have done that before so don't
get too excited like I it just doesn't
sit well with me on people like this
this press conference you're about to
watch is gonna be great it's like I just
do it yeah and we'll figure it out
afterwards show don't oh yeah I feel
like the des des did that in a lot of
ways where there it was the show don't
tell it again they didn't show anything
that made people go what but they I
liked that they kind of gave us the
forewarning of that image of there's two
work-in-progress things and they got
people you know predicting and talking
about it and then everyone guess what it
was yeah that's why people are
disappointed by it but then when we got
it I was like oh they gave us what they
said they were gonna give us and I feel
like when it comes to Microsoft I
enjoyed them saying that because it let
it was a message that they are cocky
about this and I feel like they're in a
position where they need to believe in
what they're doing because other people
are judged by the collapse here they're
not buying it
and that I mean I guess that's maybe
what's it is like if you announced it
beforehand I get the sense of you maybe
you don't believe that you're
kind of like saying it before that like
in case you don't believe it we're
saying it's a fact right now sued it
because I just told you yeah but I was
proud of Xbox for not like going on and
on and on about x-pac's like I was I was
concerned I'm like they're probably
gonna get into that right off the bat
and like man I don't want to spend 20
minutes just going over all of the nuts
and bolts yeah
then it was the thing to of like you
know we're talking about 42 games that
was awesome but then it was like to
finish the conference be like well of
the 42 what ones do I want to talk about
right right now right yeah okay
obviously move on from there like but
thank it's personal preference yeah and
it's like it I was sitting on the live
show right it was like Adam boys years
ago described building a PSX conference
that they wanted everyone to walk away
from their 10:00 announcements with like
three things they were excited about
right and I felt like Xbox was one was
like a little harder for me to come down
with even that out of 42 right yeah I
know that that's true I mean but I mean
I don't know is that true like for me
some of my games the show in terms of
like wow factor' anthem and and last
night and both those were in the xbox
thing and those are two games well last
night I hadn't heard of before and
anthem I was totally not interested in
I'm not a Bioware guy but seeing that I
was I hope I'm now interested like they
sold me and I think that the
presentation they did at actor yeah Xbox
was awesome
sure yeah that's a good point so can
there be a case with Ubisoft really
people are saying they oh yeah
just because it Beyond Good and Evil
well no I feel like Ubisoft had a really
good showing of a lot of games that
spoke to different people um rabid
surprise people there's like balance a
little bit of everything yeah I had a
spice the teaser projecting something
we're probably not gonna see until 2019
2020 something that we are gonna see
recently like like having the
affirmation of Rabbids having like
surprisingly looking at being like this
kind of looks difficult and and charming
and like I don't hate these rabid you
know Mario characters as much as I
thought I would
exactly yeah that's what I thought too
and then I watch the gameplays oh it's
XCOM on swift mario alright yeah okay I
could play that yeah I don't know again
I do think that this year there's a lot
of negativity about the press
conferences in general just like oh man
it's kind of a shitty year for e3 and I
think it's not shitty it's just not this
fantastic event that it was in prior
years I
one of the big reasons to that and one
of the points you're driving at is the
same reason Nintendo I think clearly one
is because Nintendo caught us off-guard
Playstation came out and shadow was the
big thing right xbox came out and it we
new crackdown you new state of decay you
knew about the Xbox but you know about
Scorpio is what we called it we have
them was being shown exactly and so it
was like you knew it like coming into
all these things Destiny's already had
this event there's on like we're getting
in there it's like yeah I'm excited to
know more and see more but it's not
gonna blow my hair back this isn't
something coming and this isn't xem you
you know coming back but ya know I think
that overall though it's like it's the
surprise factor that was lacking a lot
of it but what they made up for is the
fact that I think that there is more
quality game shown across all the
contras Shedden III history ever Wow
bold claim I think so okay well I think
challenge someone look through every
year make a list check it twice I'll
give you this by Nintendo ten like that
Mario reveal was probably the kiddie
estai I was during all of those press
conferences like coming yeah I know sort
thing what I wanted caught today yeah
and I was actually gonna make a point
oh you know when we were talking about
it before the press conference that was
like I bet when we see Mario it'll we
won't know it's Mario right away they'll
do that again because we saw the city
before and you saw like new dog sit like
way whoa you know I am I going out of
the street and it's like if you if you
were to like grab the average Nintendo
fan and be like what is the absolute
opposite of Mario and it's like a
prehistoric beast clearly okay the last
thing everyone next gen Yoshi alright so
we all agree any said no one III will
acquiesce again have an opinion easy
allies he wanted to campy everybody
wanted to bait he's bringing it just let
me know in the debates over and then all
you know they don't you know debate two
hours enough the debate is Ovaltine
attendant endo won
Ubisoft 1 Wow buzz it Warren Bethesda
PlayStation Wow
Nintendo 1 yeah Xbox all right Wow would
you say Xbox and ps4 were pretty even
you know
no okay Oh offending some people at the
top right neither day Brandon Jones
thank you for coming on thank you guys
so much man you can't try to have an
opinion now go to the Allies get out of
here we love you I love you
Iran Jones Brandon Jones everybody what
a nice young man
thank you all for watching along with us
here III 2017 thank you all for coming
in person um you clap for yourselves
that one oh wait what what was the Jeb
Bush please clap
next up saving the k2 okay you're
getting out here I'm out good when it's
a Greg Miller game Greg super excited
for I kick everybody else Apple I got a
do-over yeah
who's excited for state indicate ooh
yeah all right good good good